American women
god designed you this way you
I don't…I don't care
if you like to hear this or not it doesn’t really matter
god designed you this way so it is the way it is right but
your number one priority…the first thing
your first priority should be taking care of a man
and the first…your first priority should be taking care of an American man
he reminds me of this table book that I have
it's called Are Men Obsolete
and it's actually a transcript of a debate that took place in 2013 in Toronto
and the debaters look at just how much gender norms have changed
in the last 100 years so for tens of thousands of years
men were just assumed to be the dominant secks
and they primarily relied on law
religion and brute force as a means to force women to stay with them
or make it nearly impossible for women to lead a life without a male companion
but everything has changed in the last 100 years
women have came bursting into all of these spaces
that we were historically excluded from
so the workforce education politics
sports everything
and a lot of men just haven't adapted instead of just evolving
there's a whole group of men
like this creator who are just trying to bring back the good old days
trying to once again use religion to tell women that god
(conveniently also a male had a male son
and his 12 male best friends) all said that your purpose
and your highest priority
should be to serve men
they're trying to bring back laws that we know have the consequence
of making it harder for women to leave male partners
by eliminating access to abortion and reducing access to contraception
conservatives are also trying to make it harder to get a divorce
they wanna end no fault divorce
and it should be noted that women initiate nearly 70% of divorces
so if you make it harder to get a divorce
you are disproportionately impacting women's ability to leave male partners
anyways recommend this little book here
really short uh
if you get it let me know what you think.. are men obsolete?